number of eights given to each candidate
was as follows Jeremy Hunt 46,656 Horace
Johnson 92153 and therefore I give
notice that Boris Johnson is elected as
the leader of the conservative
[Applause]
well thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Carol
okay thank you so much thank you sir
Thank You Charles thank you very much
Brandon for a fantastic fantastic well
organized campaign I think it did a lot
of credit as as Brandon has just said to
our party to our values and to I our
ideals but I want to begin by thanking
my opponent Jeremy
by common consent an absolutely
formidable campaigner and a great leader
and a great politician
Jeremy in the course of twenty hussies
in more I mean 20 hustings or hustings
style events it was more than three
thousand miles by the way it's about
seven thousand miles that we did criss
crossing the country you've been
friendly
you've been good-natured you've been a
font of excellent ideas all of which I
propose to steal and above all I want to
thank our outgoing leader Theresa May
for her extraordinary service to this
party and to this country it was a
privilege
it was a privilege to serve in her
cabinet and to see the passion and
determination that she brought to the
many causes that are her legacy from
equal pay for men and women to tackling
the problems of mental health and racial
discrimination in the criminal justice
system Thank You Teresa
thank you and I want to thank all of you
all of you here today and obviously on
everybody in the Conservative Party for
your hard work for your campaigning for
your public spirit and obviously for the
extraordinary honor and privilege that
you've just conferred on me and I know
that there will be people around the
place who will question the wisdom of
your decision and there may even be some
people here who still wonder what quite
what they have done and I would just
point out to you that and of course
nobody no one party no one person has a
monopoly of wisdom but if you look at
the history of the last 200 years of
this party's existence you will see that
it is we conservatives who have had the
best insights I think into human nature
and in the best into the best insights
into how to manage the jostling sets of
instincts in the human heart and time
and again it is to us that the people of
this country have turned to get that
balance right between the instincts to
own your own house your own home to earn
and spend your own money to look after
your own family good instincts proper
instincts noble instincts and the
equally noble instinct to share and to
give everyone a fair chance in life and
to look after the poorest and the
neediest and to build a great society
and on the whole in the last 200 years
it is we conservatives who have
understood best how to encourage those
instincts to work together in harmony to
promote the good of the whole country
and today at this pivotal moment in our
history we again have to reconcile two
sets
two noble sets of instincts between the
deep desire for friendship and free
trade and mutual support in security and
defense between Britain and our European
partners and the simultaneous desire
equally deep and heartfelt for
democratic self-government in this
country and of course there some people
say that they're in irreconcilable and
it just can't be done and indeed I read
in my Financial Times this morning
devoted reader than I am seriously it's
a great great great great British great
British brand I read in my Financial
Times this morning that there are no
incoming leader no incoming leader has
ever faced such a daunting set of
circumstances it said well I look at you
this morning and I ask myself do you
look daunted do you feel daunted I don't
think we I don't think you look remotely
daunting to me and I think that we know
that we can do it and that the people of
this country are trusting in us to do it
and we know that we will do it and we
know the mantra of the campaign that has
just gone by in case you've forgotten it
you probably have it is deliver brexit
unite the country and defeat Jeremy
Corbyn
[Applause]
I know I know sucked somewhere there was
already pointed out that deliver your
knight and defeat was not the perfect
acronym for an election campaign since
our portion aliy it spells dud but they
forgot the final E my friends IVA
energized and I say I say to all the
doubters dude we are going to energize
the country we're going to get brexit
done
on october 30 was going to take
advantage of all the opportunities that
it will bring in a new spirit of can-do
and we are once again going to believe
in ourselves and what we can achieve it
like some slumbering giant we are going
to rise and ping off the guy ropes of
self-doubt and negativity with better
education better infrastructure more
police fantastic full fiber broadband
sprouting in every household we are
going to unite this amazing country and
we are going to take it forward I thank
you all very much for the incredible
honor that you have just done me I will
work flat-out from now on with my team
that I will build I hope in the next few
days to repay your confidence but in the
meantime the campaign is over and the
work begins thank you all very much